i'm off the grid for august but cnn is
still a propaganda network
about the dystopian myths of red america
basically describing how let's take the
average fox news viewer
is is what they're told about blue
states and about big cities what are
those dystopian myths what do people
need to know about that
well first of all there's the specific
issue of the whole black lives matter uh
demonstrations which a large part of the
country certainly a lot of the mail i
get people think that you know lots of
manhattan was burned to the ground they
think that this was an enormously
destructive thing when in fact yes there
was some arsenal looting but actually
really not very much in in a country the
size of the united states and for
demonstrations that size so they
that's because whenever we're talking
about the january 6 hearings the likes
of sean hannity always say well why
aren't you investigating the summer of
2020 riots that's what they say
basically every day
yeah and you're you're in manhattan
right i mean you you know that there
there there is not a burned out shell it
just this just never happened but they
are told i mean look there were windows
shattered in my building it was awful
and we cleaned it up the next day and
that's what people do so i digress go
ahead yeah and the other is about crying
now we have in fact had a
significant surge in murders since the
pandemics uh probably because you know
social isolation and all of that which
has been nationwide and has brought it's
about as much increase in rural areas
and small towns as it is in big cities
um but the idea
and it varies a lot among cities but new
york of course is everybody's favorite
and a lot of the country thinks that new
york is an extremely dangerous place
which it once was a lot of people think
that it that new york now is new york of
1975 with uh with large
no-go areas and high murder rates when
in fact it's one of the safest places in
america even even after this rise in
crime it's still uh way way less crime
than there was uh in in 1990
so that's another area where media
coverage matters so much paul thank you
very much for coming on good talking
with you